when papa
leaves to california
i get a new roommate
my new roommate has to get up for school
come on roommate
hey
where's my new roommate
okay wait a minute i thought taika was
in bed but i can't find him anymore
what's down here
i thought i saw something
i thought i saw something
there's a spider in my bed
wait a minute
wait a minute
today
hi good morning
oh my god
i know
um today
taika
is going
to school for a half day
so he's in preschool
and you can either opt for your kid to
be a full day which is
eight to three or two
or a half day instead of calling them a
half day or whatever they call them half
day friends so i
am going to make or i'm going to pick
taika up today at 12
which is going to make him a half day
friend
because why why are you a half-day
friend today
hey
why are you a half-day friend today what
are we doing today
what is going on
you're so good well today tech is going
to be a half day friend because he is
going on an airplane because we're going
to california to celebrate my mom's
birthday um and the celebration is today
so i couldn't really drive because
tomorrow we have a concert which is
really cool and then the day after that
is sunday which would have to come back
so it only made sense to fly and
honestly
i don't know what happened to me over
the years but i just i'm scared now i'm
scared of flying
so
we'll see maybe it's all in my head and
those past couple of trips
um
they were
not not my favorite
so maybe this one will be my favorite
because i'm going to go with my monkey
dude so it's just going to be me and
tyka today
um this is going to be fun
you're excited right duty
aha
got em
let's get ready for school
so today is free dress day what's it's
spirit day so they can wear any of their
favorite team's
um clothes and pants so this is what
he's gonna wear today
he doesn't know what the raiders are
what the raiders do i barely know what
they do
um
but you know we gotta represent yeah
billy yeah dude
why are you smelling its crotch you
nasty boy
okay let's get dressed and ready for
school
okay let me see your before stand here
so we can see your before
okay before turn around
hey turn around
okay that's your hair
and after
[Music]
what are you doing dude
wait wait wait wait you'd mess up your
hair
hey where are you going dude whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
so i just picked up the little duty my
little half day friend monkey
what are we gonna do right now
okay so actually we're picking up lunch
first and then we're gonna do a little
bit of packing because taka didn't pack
some toys right
yeah
right
um and then we're gonna eat pack some
toys
and then we're gonna head to the airport
and i'm so excited for tekken to see
this because this is one of those where
we get to walk straight
from our car
right onto the plane
uh through an airplane hangar
so it's gonna be a lot of fun and it's
such a cool experience for this duty um
i didn't get to do this until i was in
my late 30s uh meaning literally last
year um so to have him experience it is
going to be so effing
red all right monkey
let me see what are you bringing with
you
miles and mckenny
yeah so you have all your toys in here
you have some headphones you have your
ipads
what oh my god
you almost forgot about it huh yeah
you put them in there i took care of you
and then over here you have all your
little snacks even though it's a
45-minute flight i got you covered okay
duty okay so who's gonna take care of
your stuff me who else is responsible
for it you nope me just you baby okay
how do you walk around with your luggage
yes
show me
yep who's gonna take care of your
luggage me who else
yep what about your backpack who's gonna
know who's gonna carry your backpack
who else is gonna carry your backpack
me that's it yep who's gonna carry
mama's backpack backpack who else you
that's it what about my luggage you yeah
who else yeah
what are you gonna say go tell me i
forgot i don't know oh it's okay look
look look look there
and then you want the airplane and you
put the luggage up
are you ready to go yeah
careful okay i don't want you to fall
okay let's go
okay come on
just got to the airport and my duty fell
asleep
oh oh oh
you ready to go
he had a little bloody nose so there's
some like little blood on the tip of his
nose you ready to rock and roll yeah i
stayed on the airplane
am i excited yeah i'm excited to go with
you
too
all right let's rock out yeah
you're so cute i love you so much
huh
where's mama
i'm right in front of you i'm right here
it's okay you're still sleeping i'll
leave you alone
okay okay let's go
look at this guy
he's ready with all his luggage okay
it's gonna be bumpy okay so you gotta
push it
he's a little drunk driver
there you go thank you whoops
can't forget spiderman you're welcome
thank you
come on duty
so we are at gsx and this guy
he already knows the rules no one's
taking care of it but himself
you're doing a great job dude
i love it i love what i'm seeing mama
has her stuff like it has his stuff
we're doing it we're doing it
good job
okay so we're waiting on our flight but
look on that window over here come here
you're gonna get on that guy
yeah you see it yeah
it's pretty
[Music]
oh
okay let's just go how about you put on
that thing on that helicopter thing and
you have my put on there
there we go judy
there we go
whoa look at that guy
it's so big
look at that
you're gonna get on that one isn't it
cool yeah
i can see it because i'm tall yeah you
can see outside the window oh yeah
good job
yeah when you're in the car
are you excited
you're gonna see everything that's so
cool
still on the ground we haven't left yet
we're about to leave yeah we need to
tell them where we're going where are we
going
to grandma's house okay i don't think
wow
seven
to the house
[Music]
are you excited
[Music]
it's coming closer
we're gonna land
[Music]
landing
that was crazy that was crazy
[Music]
[Music]
oh well he's in a different city
[Music]
okay you gotta turn around okay ready
happy birthday
[Applause]
[Laughter]
nobody's going to blow on it
[Applause]
okay guys i went a little bit lighter on
my hair i know it was abrupt
we just uh got off of the airplane tycho
was so stoked meeting two female pilots
saw my mom it's her birthday my brother
picked this up so things got kind of
bonkers because it was all a surprise
and you know with surprises sometimes
things don't go as planned
so
that's what happened yesterday but
today's a new day um spent a lot of time
with my family today um just got back
from the salon went a lot lighter
because it was just you know with hair
you have to be very careful um depending
on like everyone's hair texture and the
way it
colors and does all this [ __ ] is all so
unique to the unique person
um that with my hair the first pass that
you guys saw that i did you know on my
instagram and here um was the first time
that i processed my hair and i bleached
it really uh
uh like a lot
um i was gonna say harshly but i didn't
bleach it harshly bleach is harsh
um on the freeway right now so excuse me
but
uh and i didn't have time to spend like
another eight hours at the salon you
know doing a slow process so i waited
about two weeks until i knew it was
coming back uh for my mom's birthday
and um i did it again so we went lighter
no breakage no damage
um
no breakage no damage i see that because
anytime you bleach your hair you're
already [ __ ] up your hair like it's
just
it's a guarantee you're [ __ ] up your
hair but i'm not attached to my hair as
you guys may have already um picked up
on i
i'm not attached to too many material
physical things
um so that's why i think i'm so
courageous
when it comes to exploring new
uh styles or just anything on myself
right like i got a [ __ ]
hand tattoo like it doesn't make any
goddamn sense
to the normal person
but you know again because i'm not
attached to anything um
i just say [ __ ] it let's do it you know
um so yeah going home now
but if you guys are ever in the glendora
area please visit this place called
classic coffee it's a mom and pop shop
there's only one
um it's in glendora but they make the
best chai latte
iced chai lattes that you will ever
freaking have
i just
picked up four of them for my family and
some scones and stuff for this morning
i don't think they've ever had to be
sent my mom i
always got my mom everything but like my
brother and my sister-in-law i don't
think i've gotten it for them yet so
um it's a 30-minute drive back
from glendora back to
east l.a where my family lives
so hopefully they still taste good they
already look not so cute
look at this
it's usually really frothy because i
think they blend it
um
oh god i'm just salivating at the idea
of like drinking this chive [ __ ]
latte ah so good okay but on that note
you guys um i think i've vlogged long
enough for this one
tomorrow i'm doing something really
really fun with anthony lee david so
our friend son of mike bart
um we're gonna go to a really cool
concert and i can't wait to show that to
you guys first concert in about two
years
[ __ ] stoked
okay thank you bye have a great day
kisses bye okay bye okay bye no you hang
up no you hang up no you hang up okay
i'll hang up
hi
all right today we are going to smoking
grooves this guy didn't register his
tags we are at
oh oh oh oh oh
we're at the world famous the one and
the only barbell brigade but before i
even say anything else
[Laughter]
wait what
okay so this is hilarious
we met up with anthony
uh you guys also make
we met up with them showed them our gym
um and then we went to get some at
mcdonald's because people are hungry
fair enough we went we tried to find
parking the event is actually a couple
blocks away from barbell brigade that's
why we were here in the first place i
should have mentioned that i didn't
sorry
we went we got mcdonald's we ate in the
papa's truck bed
we ended up back at barbell just because
there's no parking everything's super
packed
it's been an hour people need to pee
back here again
we're just gonna leave papa's truck
right at barbell and then we're gonna go
to the concert
it's been an hour and we've done
nothing
it's [ __ ] hilarious
fair
so you know you're getting old
all right so finally we're on the move
the crew we're walking we're on foot
it's gonna be a good day it's gonna be a
good day this is a good
lucky coincidence because it's at the la
historic center and it's really close to
barbara we tried to park over there it
was a pain in the ass a good thing we're
only right over the bridge so we kind of
got lucky with the secret spot but a lot
of people later on i feel like they're
gonna slam themselves into that slam
slam
yeah so excited um
who knows they're supposed to go on to
like 10 p.m so we'll see how long we we
stay here because uh if you can't tell
we're kind of tired old people now you
know what i mean so
we'll see how it goes it'll be fun
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
okay
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what can i do keep getting money 20
hours just like you i used to hustle
hard till i made up
so the concert is over and bart had this
genius idea because everyone's feet hurt
this is what we're going to be doing
tonight
hey it's up to y'all
a bittersweet moment
every single week because we've been in
ollie every single week and the
bittersweet moment is
we're going back home
and i only see it's bittersweet because
um i really do enjoy when i see tyka
playing with his cousins um
and like having grandma around and then
waking up and having grandma make
breakfast like i didn't even get that
when i was living here
um so every time we come here it's like
it's like a new special treatment that
we all receive and i hate leaving it
but it's kind of cool that we do leave
it because uh when we come back then we
get it but when we were living here no
people were just like well why am i
going to see you i can see you any time
i want you're only like 30 minutes out
or whatever um but now every time we see
each other it's very intentional and
it's very uh
focused and it's very uh warm and happy
not that it wasn't before but i don't
know man it's just it's just cool being
back
and we got papa here
driving to
his house driving to grandpa's house
right now because
part of the whole special treatment that
i'm talking about we lived here before
this never happened before but right now
every time we go back home we have to
stop at grandpa's house because grandpa
has to see taika taika what do you say
when you see okay
[Music]
take
a
he was just munching i know we were just
here
yes because he's eating these guys he's
like papa and he loves his honey mustard
chips because we had uh he was like
munching away in the background it was
so funny because earlier he knew we're
gonna see grandpa so he's like he wanted
to get it right too which is so cute and
he goes but do i say
how yeah yeah i'm like yeah that's
exactly how you say it so he's been
practicing because uh when he speaks
chinese it makes my dad so happy too
yeah but this guy's out now
well uh
bye-bye yeah yay
you're awake
well yeah we went to grandpa's house to
pick up the chairs that are back there
but you were sleeping but he left you a
surprise
we can't go back there we're too far now
but can i show you what he gave you
okay look right here
your grandpa loves you so much
and him for what baby
stuff you got the crunchy stuff on your
mouth okay i'm gonna clean it for you
okay
uh-huh look at papa now watching
munching away sending like a little
chick monk
we are about two hours now away from
home
uh the defeat is up we're about to stop
making these little picks up to get some
lunch because it's about three and all
we've had was breakfast this morning so
um
yeah
thank you so much for watching
we're done we're out here
yep
yep
oh that's all he had just a yeah boy
okay thank you uh i hope you enjoyed our
four little days
uh sewn on together this is like a
different experimental style of vlogging
that we're doing let me know if you like
it but until then